gemma's influence over club matters the
shifting narrative of john teller's
death the galindo cartel deal
keep watching as we get into some of the
most questionable things from sons of
anarchy that we just let slide
we're not sure any of the questionable
things we've come up with really rival
the seemingly boundless loyalty that
harry opie winston shows sam crowe he
does five years in chino prison after
former member kyle hobart ditches him
and tries to stay on the straight and
narrow upon his release in order to keep
his wife donna happy nonetheless it's
clear opie misses the brotherhood he
enjoyed as a member of the club as
evidenced by the way he is eventually
drawn back in by best friend jax teller
to make some extra money unfortunately
repeated attempts by atf agent june
stahl to get opi to turn on the club
result in president clay morrow
believing opie truly is a rat so clay
orders alexander tigg trager to kill him
as fans know tig mistakenly kills donna
instead opie of course is at first
unaware his own club is responsible for
his wife's death
eventually tig confesses out of guilt at
which point opie gives him a savage
beating he still stays with the club
nonetheless seeing stahl as the real
villain it doesn't hurt that clay spares
his father piney after the elder winston
fires a gun at him twice but clay has
only hit paws on eliminating members of
opie's family he kills piney in season 4
over letters jax's father wrote which
indicate his seeming awareness that clay
and jax's mother gemma teller are going
to kill him opie shoots clay twice but
is still unable to operate alongside him
and tig up until he finally gives his
own life for the club in prison in
season 5.
[Music]
jack's teller is ostensibly all about
family first his devotion to his
brothers and sam crowe is rivaled only
by opie's jax fights to maintain custody
of his son abel from his drug-addicted
ex-wife wendy
please don't hate me
you need to get help wendy i know i know
i will i promise this time i promise
he drags the entire sam crow crew to
ireland in season 3 to track abel down
after he's kidnapped by true ira bad guy
cameron hayes jax actually considers
leaving sam crow to get his wife tara
and their two sons away from the outlaw
life and of course he sacrifices himself
in the series finale so that sam crowe
can remain operational given the mayhem
vote against him but in his travels to
the old sod jax learns he has a
half-sister trinity a product of an
affair between his father john teller
and maureen ashby a fact of which he
learns just in the nick of time before
the two got too cozy with each other
obviously they're both pretty
embarrassed to have almost hooked up
with a blood relative and maybe that
awkwardness is the reason we never hear
from trinity and maureen again despite
jax being more focused on family than
the entire fast and furious saga his
long-lost sibling remains a season 3
ghost and doesn't surface again for the
remaining four seasons of sons of
anarchy the awkwardness of their
introduction notwithstanding it doesn't
make sense that we never hear from the
ashby's again
we're thinking maybe jack's teller needs
a dictionary could someone turn him to
the page that defines the word
legitimate we're all about him taking
sam crowe away from drugs and guns and
the respective precarious relationships
with cartels and the irish republican
army that those dealings represent but
getting into the companion business is
no less illegal
look we get that nero padilla is a
charming guy and if we had to pick a
fictional character of shady repute with
whom our outlaw mother would hook up it
would be him we could debate the
respective moralities of the sons being
smugglers against working in the sex
trade but at the end of the day there's
simply no getting around the simple fact
that they're both against the law trying
to take the club legit by leaving drugs
and guns in favor of escorts is like
trying to lose weight by simply
switching from full calorie coke to full
calorie pepsi it's just not going to
work of course all of that being said
it's also true that jax's first attempt
to get the club to go legit would have
worked if clay hadn't torpedoed it
putting sam crow in the adult film
business in season 2 with luanne
delaney's film studio karakara was at
least a legitimate business venture
operating within the law
of course caracara also provided a
source of relationship drama between jax
and future wife taryn knowles but it's
also where opie met his second wife lila
juan carlos juice ortiz manages a lot of
the non-muscle tasks sam crowe faces
over the course of the sons of anarchy
timeline he's technologically proficient
and serves the role of an mc's version
of a hacker and tech support but he's
also prone to making his share of stupid
decisions perhaps the most notable of
which is turning against the club when
sheriff eli roosevelt blackmails him
back in the day when the sons of anarchy
motorcycle club was first formed the
legendary first nine the founding
members of the redwood original chapter
wrote their bylaws with some rules that
would not age well among them was the
provision that prohibited black men as
members sheriff roosevelt blackmails
juice on behalf of season four's primary
antagonist lincoln potter knowing that
juice's father is black threatening to
reveal his heritage to the club if he
doesn't turn snitch fearing being kicked
out of the club juice does potter's
bidding and steals a brick of cocaine
which will provide proof that sam crowe
is mixed up with the galindo cartel and
even kills eric miles when he's caught
in the act trying to return the drugs
doesn't make sense
miles
the inanity we ignore is that juice
would rather risk getting caught out as
a rat for which he'd almost certainly be
killed then potentially get kicked out
of the club over an outdated rule that
it's possible no one in the modern club
would even care about
speaking of the outdated rules written
by the founding members of the sons of
anarchy mc in addition to people of
color women were also prohibited from
being members of the club so while it's
true that gem and tara are not patched
members of the club it's unlikely that
any woman would be able to exert as much
influence on its comings and goings as
the two of them do and gemma more than
anyone biker culture has traditionally
been patriarchal in nature and the club
that's presented on sons of anarchy is
no different don't take our word for it
people have written scholarly articles
about the persistence of patriarchy in
the world of motorcycle aficionados in
her thesis making sense of motorcycle
brotherhood women branding and
construction of self kimberly michelle
moss notes that the number of women
riders has risen over the years but is
still down around 25 of the total biker
population with 75 being men she
concludes no matter the experience used
to define or support patriarchy and
motorcycles the data shows that it still
does exist quarry user george paxalt
addressed gemma's role in the club after
laying out an impressive list of his mc
credentials he wrote gemma's position in
the club ain't gonna happen ever she'd
have been taken out back and corrected
halfway through the first episode in the
real world women do not have any
decision-making positions in a real mc
period
the mystery and uncertainty behind john
teller's death plays a crucial role in
the early development of sons of anarchy
and his figurative ghost the narrative
set forth in his manuscript the life and
death of sam crowe how the sons of
anarchy lost their way also helps set up
conflict between jax and clay jt makes
it clear he feels the club's decision to
get into guns with the true ira was a
catalyst for sam crowe's seeming
downfall and tries more than once to get
the club out of guns and into more
legitimate pursuits sound familiar of
course jax's father died shortly after
completing this manuscript so the
subtext reads that his idea wasn't
popular with a certain party who very
much wants sam crowe to continue running
guns initially we're told jt died in an
accident but the circumstances change
more than once gemma suggests that
following the death of their second son
thomas jt may have taken his own life
jt's letters to maureen ashby indicate
he feels like clay and gemma are
plotting to kill him we also find out
that wayne unser helped cover up the
fact that his bike was sabotaged so it
was murder but then it was neither an
accident nor murder because jt's
confidante jerry white insists jt would
know if his bike had been tampered with
suggesting he purposely crashed his bike
into the semi in an effort to save the
club and keep sam crowe together given
how jax met his own end we assume the
most recent version of jt's death is
what he chose to believe but the
shifting narrative on the matter of john
teller's death was definitely a source
of frustration for many sons of anarchy
fans
robert bobby elvis munson is a nuanced
and important character among the sons
of anarchy cast he serves as both a
surrogate father figure and vital
sounding board for jax talking the
volatile young man down with a skilled
and steady hand on more than one
occasion in many situations that called
for a voice of reason bobby plays that
role knowing the tension between clay
and jax is bad for the club as a whole
he also initially serves as vice
president of sam crow when jax takes the
president's patch before that bobby
elvis serves as club treasurer and it's
in this capacity that the character is
seen acting outside his normal operating
principles in season two when reviewing
the finances of the club's joint venture
with luanne delaney the carrakera adult
film studio bobby realizes luanne is
skimming and thus defrauding sam crowe
of money based on the mortal compass he
presents throughout the rest of the show
we'd expect bobby to turn luanne in to
face the consequences of her actions by
my calculations
you've been cutting us light for six
years
instead he gives in to her advances and
chooses not to disclose her theft
it's a decision that doesn't make sense
given bobby's tendency to do what's best
for the club
luanne is otto delaney's old lady
despite the fact that the prison clause
we're still not sure if that's actually
a thing in real life mc culture but we
hope not allows other members to have
relations with an old lady while her man
is in prison it's just wrong on so many
levels and not really in keeping with
the character as a whole
season 4 has a 100 critic score on
rotten tomatoes a peculiar score
considering there's a major issue with
the finale assistant u.s attorney
lincoln potter rolls into town as
members of sam crowe are released from
prison and recruits eli roosevelt the
new top dog at the san joaquin county
sheriff department to be a part of his
multi-agency task force to bring down
sam crowe the true ira and russian
organized crime all in one fell swoop
potter sows dissension in the ranks by
forcing jews to betray his club in order
to remain a member when he and roosevelt
convinced the wayward juan carlos to
steal a brick of cocaine sam crowe got
from the galindo cartel represented by
romero romeo perata and luis torres
potter is an antagonist who's ambitious
and cunning to boot in fact he's so good
that it looks like he's got all his
ducks in a row and is about to clear the
board with a massive rico case then the
cartel shows up to make that all go away
see parata and torres are actually
members of the cia working on a black
book operation and the american
government is backing the galindo cartel
in the hopes of putting other cartels
out of business and eliminating the
violence between the warring factions
amid other political reasons
it doesn't matter that potter succeeded
where others had failed because this
deus ex machina ending essentially undid
the entire season's worth of drama check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one